whether it's talking cars a lovesick
robot or just a fish looking for his son
pics are certainly know how to tug at
the heartstrings and the sequel to
Finding Nemo looks like no exception I'm
Simon and this is your entertainment
news update Finding Nemo was Pixar's
biggest hit when released in 2004 and it
remains the studio second most popular
film worldwide all these years later a
sequel has been a long time coming but
finding Dory is set to swim into
theaters next month finding Dory focuses
upon the amnesiac fish of the title and
her quest to be reunited with her family
Ellen DeGeneres returns to voice dory as
does Albert Brooks playing the clownfish
Marlon the film also stars Diane Keaton
Eugene Levy William Dafoe Idris Elba and
Dominic West in a recent interview with
Entertainment monthly director Andrew
Stanton revealed that returning to the
character after so long was more of a
challenge than expected I think I
underestimated how difficult Dory is to
write for she was built to be a
supporting character to make the other
people look good and putting her in the
spotlight and making her the main
character with short-term memory loss
proved to be very difficult very
difficult to write for and I started to
hate the person that came up with her
which was me do you think finding Dory
will live up to its predecessor or do
you think we have a cars 2 on our hands
let me know in the comments or come find
me on Twitter i'm at the Jagan all
thanks for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot
you